online
uh so you know we've got a lot of uh
really great talks
planned for today but uh to start us off
we're really happy to have uh kalisha
bullard who's gonna be telling us about
uh you know her work on communication in
multi-agent rl so i'll let you
take it away all right
thanks dylan um so i'm kalisha ballard i
am a research scientist at deepmind on
the game theory and multi-agent team i
recently started a d-mine in december um
so this work is actually from my post
doc at facebook ai research um
so yeah and so i'm gonna be discussing
some uh work that we did on zero shot
communication
um
and uh and i'll also at the end kind of
uh present some open problems and give a
bit a hint of kind of what i'm thinking
about now
um so in general i'm quite interested in
cooperative multi-agent systems
i think that the world is inherently
multi-agent which i feel like i don't
have to convince you guys about and of
course here are a couple of biological
examples um and i think that uh when we
think about cooperation particularly
because we're thinking about ways in
which we can deploy you know
technologies to
human environments then
it's going to be necessary to have
communication and coordination for human
ai coexistence and so
um my background is is quite different
from many of the speakers that we've
seen so far so i'm not coming from the
theory background actually in my phd i
focused on robots learning from humans
and then my postdoc i started looking at
multi-agent learning uh so my work is
largely motivated by these types of
domains
um so i think some of the most relevant
application domains when you think about
human ai coexistence um and or just like
ai agents um
coordinating and communicating with each
other you know self-driving vehicles are
commonly used to motivate this robots
and human environments like these robots
in a factory
um
and so these are kind of the ones that
are going to be the most
relevant high-level domains and to be
fair this talk will be quite abstract
but it's uh on a high level motivated by
these kinds of domains where you might
want agents communicating with other
agents
so imagine that you had all of these
embodied agents existing operating in
some shared environments as autonomous
vehicle ecosystem
and there's a question about how can one
learn to communicate how can the agents
learn to communicate to aid in
coordination
so you might think well what about
supervised learning from data sets or
imitation learning from demonstrations
but one challenge is that um for
supervised learning particularly because
here you have different agent
embodiments you'd need um huge existing
data sets for each of the embodiments
and also for each of the different
things that you wanted to communicate
um so
this becomes uh a really expensive way
to try to to solve the problem although
i do think that that it could complement
uh reinforcement learning but
multi-agent reinforcement learning
provides a way for agents to learn
through you know self-play or or agent
agent interactions um but then there's
this question of should agents have to
train with every potential partner to
infer general communication protocol and
what i mean when i say general here what
i mean is to be able to generalize to
other agents so for example i'm a car
agent and i learn with another agent if
i see a new car i want to be able to you
know talk to it quickly um and so this
is motivated by this idea that like we
want agents to learn protocols that will
generalize to unseen partners or this
work is
um so this work was again it was so it
was done at well what's now meta ai
ironically um
three of the five people who were that
we were all there at the time but three
of the five people are no longer there
um and then jacob was my primary
collaborator on this work um
so we're looking at the emergence of
zero shock communication protocols
um and so the motivating research
question here is it's motivated by this
idea that
so again i came from in my my phd i was
thinking about robot robots learning
from humans and so coming into the post
doc that was the context that i had been
you know had been very familiar with and
uh there was this interesting question
around you know enabling agents to
communicate through action which is what
you might expect for embodied agents um
independent of what their embodiment is
and this is something that humans do so
even if you think about embodied agents
that want to communicate in a way that
humans can interpret this is useful
um all right so that's the motivating
research question uh and then first a
bit of background so first learning a
communication protocol so let's say you
have a population of these three agents
so red blue and orange and they have
some set of communicative goals that
they've been given
um
so what we want is for each age in the
population to learn to generate messages
for every communicative goal in the
library that's been given to them
uh and so the learning problem is for
every agent to learn a policy mapping
the set of communicative goals to the
message space
um okay so this is basically a type of
uh so this is basically done through
signaling games and in the uh
multi-agent communication literature
people typically talk about referential
games so i'll use those interchangeably
here um so the premise of the game is
that you have a sender agent that is
given some referent or a communicative
goal
and it needs to generate a message for
that and the receiver agent must infer
what um what communicative goal is being
signaled so input would be some goal g
alice sends a message m
uh bob makes a prediction about what
goal alice was trying to communicate and
then the loss is some distance between
the two um so important assumptions for
this typical problem setting of this
referential game is that it's a discrete
communication channel uh which means
that um typically each message is an
individual action although in more
recent work people have started looking
at some sequence
of symbols um but that exponentially
increases the size of the message space
um and
and uh
the cheap talk setting where there's no
cost to actually taking action
um so this is just kind of a visual
sample of some of the recent prior work
in multi-agent communication in the deep
learning era it's not intended to be
exhaustive but to briefly illustrate
um
and
so these are the important assumptions
that we relax in this work uh i uh given
that the audience here has been quite
theoretical i decided to focus on the
the top one
uh no i'm sorry the bottom one which is
the relaxing the assumption of cheat
talk and thinking about costly messages
but i'm happy to talk about the work in
continuous uh settings offline
um okay
so the problem formalism is this is a
fully cooperative uh problem setting so
we make the assumption that
communicative goals are given ahead of
time and the protocol is supposed to
emerge
um so there's no data or supervisory
signal given
uh and so this is formalized as a
decentralized partially absorbable
markov decision process a debt palm dp
um and so the standard definition of
deck palmdps you have n agents in our
case in will be two a sender and a
receiver um some finite set of states a
set of joint observations uh is is
generally defined but each agent can
have private individual observations
um there's going to be a set of joint
actions as as typical and in this work
all the actions are actually
communication actions
um
and then the the reward here is a shared
reward a team reward
and then we also add the set of goals um
so you can think about it as like a goal
conditioned decomvp
um and so visually
effectively you have these two learning
agents and there's going to be a set of
observations that they can observe from
the world of course the environment the
dynamics are non-stationary because the
agents are co-learning
um
and then agent
agent i can observe agent jay's action
and vice versa
and then the goal is to maximize the
total shared return per episode
so um so we we do a typical um training
regime for
uh cooperative settings so centralized
training decentralized execution so
agents can share information
at training time back propagate signal
et cetera but um
but
at test time or at inference time agents
are expected to make decisions using
their individual policy
um okay
so i'm going to talk about give context
about the zero shot coordination problem
setting and then talk about the the
problem setting we or the variant of
this or the instance of this we
introduced which is sierra shock
communication
so um zero shot coordination was um
was introduced at uh in 2020 and this
was also work done at the time facebook
ai research
um
and
basically the problem setting is such
that it is this fully cooperative
problem setting and agents uh must
coordinate at test time with other
agents who have been independently
trained so effectively at test time
you're gonna see um a novel partner
um in this work they introduced
equivalence mappings or symmetries of of
of policies which are bijective mappings
which i'll go into more depth about in
the talk
and also they formalize symmetries for
each element of the underlying uh
deckpom
so we're going to build upon this work
so um in our work we formalize the
problem setting of zero shot
communication which is an instance of
the zero shot coordination setting where
the goal is to learn a communication
protocol that effectively generalizes to
unseen agents
so
agents are trained in self-play so um
say so i'm gonna describe the green
these are two different pairs of
self-play agents agreeing the blue pair
i'll uh describe the green pair so let's
call our sender agent pi one always
and um pi one is given some gold g and
it can take a private observation one
and they can also take an action a let's
call our receiver agent pi2 pi 2 can
observe action a taken by
pi one it gets its own private
observation and then it makes a
prediction about um the the goal being
communicated so this is just the
signaling game
so at test time
um
in order to evaluate zero shot
communication what we do is effectively
swap the agent so every every sender
will be uh paired with um every receiver
that it's not seen before and vice versa
and so uh this is zero shot because this
is a an agent that trained independently
from you
so you might say okay well this sounds
you know very reasonable what's the
problem with just training using
self-play so the problem is that
self-play has many equivalent but
incompatible joint policies um or in our
communication protocols a joint policy
and successful coordination means
agreeing on a protocol which means
converging on the same optimum so let's
say that this is this is some simplified
um optimization landscape
say each of these um
red dots represents um a communication
protocol an optimal communication
protocol so you can imagine
um that one is you know one of these is
german one is french one is english
naturally they're not that far apart but
just so you get the idea the intuition
um if you have agents um send the
receiver agents training completely
independently of one another there's no
reason to believe a priority that
they'll converge on the same optimum
right and so what we want to do is
effectively bias the optimization
landscape such that
if a sender receiver um agents train
separately or train independently given
that they will initialize in different
parts of the space that they still given
an optimization algorithm that is
effective they still will converge on
the globally optimal solution there's
only one globally optimal protocol
on the previous like what's the
role of the additional observation
with all you're trying to do is
communicate the goal um or what would
the observation be in practice
that's a good question that's really
just the formalism so in this matrix
slide game that we're going to talk
about uh there's not really one but
actually in our continuous experiments
uh where we had like a
like a simulated arm
then it could observe um the actual uh
xyz will get y'all of each of the joints
so all right so our general approach is
to induce bias with priors in the
solution space and we want to use real
world constraints to engender this
globally
optimal protocol so we don't want to be
just arbitrary
and um and then we want to then the
other thing is to adapt the learning
objective to learn some distribution
over equivalent global optimum so we're
going to exploit this idea of
equivalence classes or symmetries in
order to
um
uh infer what the equivalent global
optima are
so um priors from real world setting so
the first thing is since this is
inspired by agents that are
communicating through physical action
um or through action in general action
costs there's in in terms of energy
right so there's a cost this is no
longer cheap talk setting communication
is costly there's a cost to actually
having to exert energy to take action
and the other um is that there's a
non-unifor non-uniform distribution over
the different communicative goals so um
it it's pretty uh common in the
quantitative linguistics literature to
use this zippy and distribution over uh
words or sentences it's been um seen to
be
um useful for like uh human behavior and
so we use this to induce a non-uniform
distribution over the communicative
goals so when you put these two together
what this incentivizes is a minimal
effort protocol because effectively what
you want is um
in goals that occur more frequently with
a higher probability you want them to be
mapped to actions that have a lower cost
or energy um and so overall what you get
is minimizing effort in your in your
protocol
now this picture that i'm showing you um
you know uh implies that there should be
one globally optimal um
one globally optimal protocol given this
uh
so actually okay i'm just going to skip
this slide so um but what about if you
have symmetries in realistic
communication
so now let's say i am this um
this uh car agent and i want to tell
another car to go ahead and there may be
three
um
you know uh ways of doing this that use
the same amount of energy so i could
weigh with my left hand
to say come it's your turn i go with my
right hand to say it comes your turn or
i could do like a head nod to say like
you go
um
so effectively in a very if this were
your only communicative goal these will
be three simple protocols that are all
different protocols and the challenge is
that um these are equivalent minimal
effort protocols but they're
incompatible so um if i'm a if i'm a
receiver that trained with a sender that
wave with his left hand
uh at test time when i face off a sender
that is like nodding i'm going to have
difficulty we're gonna have a
communication failure because i we
didn't learn compatible policies
so how does this impact the optimization
landscape so the
the nice picture i showed you with one
global optimum is going to be the case
if you have no redundancy in the action
or goal space so every action has a
distinct cause every goal has a distinct
likelihood there's only one way to map
actions to goals to minimize effort but
if you have any redundancy so many
different actions have the same cost
um
which is like different actions exerting
the same amount of energy or many
different goals have the same likelihood
then there are multiple ways to map uh
to basically do a mapping that is
minimal effort um and we'll focus on
action symmetry in this work
okay so now i'll go back to the picture
that i kind of skipped um
oh that's unfortunate it cuts off okay
so um
on the left
okay okay okay
okay so on the so the the left the left
column is a this is a visual
visualization of a joint of two
different joint policies for an orange
pair of orange senders who are appearing
a green center receiver pair so i'm
going to go through each column so the
left column is a visualization the
sender policy the middle column is the
visualization the receiver policy and
the right column is a visualization of
the um
uh the confusion matrix where send a
receiver agree
um or you know okay so um on the left
side on the left column if you look at
the vertical axis this represents the
input for the sender so it is actually
um different communicative goals so
there's like zero through four so
there's five different communicative
goals
um
and the x-axis is actions so there's i
think 15 different actions shown here
um
the receiver column uh the
the vertical axis is input again so
there's different actions that it could
see by the sender and then the um
horizontal axis is outputs a different
uh goals that it could uh predict
and then the right side again is where
cinder and receiver
um the joint probability so effectively
what we want to see is probability mass
along the diagonal because it means that
sender and receiver agree
um so the other thing here to note is
that
um
in this left column
the uh
the
the intents are ordered by
frequency so the lower rank the more
probable or more frequent that intent
occurs so that's what that line is
supposed to show you and then the
actions are order by cost so as you go
to the right the actions are more costly
and you see these equals um classes
these are supposed to be like energy
classes basically so actions that are
grouped together so there's only one
action that exerts zero energy and it's
action zero and then you see um there's
four or four or five different actions
that exert energy one et cetera all
right so basically there are these are
both optimal joint policies um if you're
training using self-play because um each
of them is going to map intent one which
is the most or the intense year which is
the most frequently occurring intent to
the action that exerts no energy there's
only one way to map that but then there
are four different ways that um there
are four different actions that you can
map for any of the intents zero through
four right and you still get a minimal
effort policy because all those actions
exert the same amount of energy so
they're effectively
symmetric they're you know any
permutation of them is still a minimal
effort protocol so in self-play the
agents do very well but even in this
simple game you see that um for
zero-shot coordination and cross-play
they only get around 45 and it turns out
that um intent zero the the most
frequently occurring one that occurs
about 44 of the time so basically the
best they can do is always guessing the
most frequently occurring intent um
because again
the any permutation of the other four
actions is still going to be optimal
from a self-play perspective
so how do we address this gap in
communication efficacy between training
partners and novel partners is the
question
all right so
we introduce a method um
so if you do training during self-play
again just like i said um here's the the
self-play objective where
um you're trying to
maximize you know some objective for um
you're trying to learn some maximal
joint policy and it will converge
effectively deterministic uh in terms of
like converging on one of these policies
right so i want these joint policies
putting all the probability mass on one
protocol and so the problem of course is
if my partner conversion on different
protocol we have communication failure
um so this is where we so other so this
the the work that i talked about we are
building upon this um
work um other play that introduced this
this zero shot coordination problem
setting also introduced um a
modification to the self-play objective
such that now it's actually going to
maximize over
um equivalences over policies so uh
basically if i'm
pi one i'm not only learning i'm not
learning a
a policy that only is going to be
optimal with respect to my training
partner it should be optimal also with
respect to any symmetry equivalent
policies
um so it's going to learn some uh some
mapping between uh pi one and a
distribution over all symmetry
equivalent policies for pi two
so maximizes over equivalence classes um
yes so in this world okay so the
equivalence classes come from the
environment from some grounding
environment so like in my example of
like the waving
phys from a physics perspective i use
the same amount of energy if i wave from
my right versus my left hand and so this
work the other play will assume that
those are given
um and so the the contribution here
what i'll talk about quasi-equivalence
discovery is discovering those those
symmetries but it is the case that the
symmetries come from just grounding in
the environment
and their training is like done together
it's not decentralized
it's centralized training so agents can
they do have separate policies but they
can communicate during
um they can pass signal during training
okay so we want to build up on that so
we're going to use that objective as
part of our algorithm so we're going to
build upon that work
um but the first thing that we do is uh
analyze theoretically how the objective
function for the communication game
changes using
this maximization over equivalence
classes
so um
so typically for uh
for a signaling game you would be
maximizing um your log your the the
probability
of um
so p of p sub pi of g given g
is the probability under the particular
joint policy pi that the receiver will
predict g given that the sender was
communicating g so that that basically
the center and receiver agree that's
when you have communication success
so what we're adding here is um
typically it's not costly communication
so we're adding some cost for the joint
policy which is coming from actions
being taken and also looking at some
expectation over equivalence classes
so it would have already been an
expectation over goals but now we're
looking at an expectation of our
equivalence classes as well
so how does that change the the overall
objective because those are two
significant things so the green is what
changes from the previous line um
so i'm just expanding uh the left i'm
just expanding each one of these on the
left side it's just like the log
probability for each individual goal
times it's prior on the right side c of
a is the cost of the um a particular
action
times um the probability of taking that
action by the sender times the prior for
that goal and we do that over taking
expectation over all the goals
um so now the next um line what i've
what i've done is effectively um
expanded what's inside of the summation
so um looking at the log probability of
the joint
with respect to the joint policy really
means looking at the
probability of the receiver policy
predicting g given some equivalence
class over actions times the sender
policy predicting a given the original
goal
um
and so what we want to do is uh pull the
summation out of the log because
you know you can't really do anything
with that so we use jensen's inequality
to be able to pull this out and now it
puts a greater than or equal to uh
sign on the outside and then on the
right side here i'm just condensing
notation and saying we're gonna take
some expectation
um over the actions uh over the cost of
the actions taken
given the joint policy
um so
so now this separates into i mean so now
we can actually separate what's inside
of the log into two separate terms and
so on the left side we have the log
probability of this receiver policy
um on the right side we are in the
middle we have a log probability of the
sender policy so we wanted to maximize
the log likelihood effectively
and um
after a few steps which i don't really
show here then you can show that
effectively um there are a couple key
things that i want to highlight this is
optimizing for
which is maximizing mutual information
between goals and equivalence classes
over actions and minimizing effort
so
in particular maximizing mutual
information what that effectively tells
us is
um given the joint policy that you're
learning if you see if the if the agents
see a particular goal they should be
able to with high probability predict
what
what equivalence class of actions has
probability mass so effectively which
equivalence class of actions maps to
that particular goal
and um
and with if you see an action or an
equivalence class of actions with high
probability being able to predict which
goal is being communicated so um so this
is you know an analysis to show that we
started with this log probability you
know of the goal given the the goal in
the beginning so this communication
efficacy but what it really is trying to
optimize for is mutual information
between goals and equivalence classes
over actions so how can we obtain these
equivalence class
maps and mappings becomes the next
question
um all right so a key limitation in the
in the prior work is that they assume
the equivalence mappings of the
symmetries are given but this is a
limiting assumption in practice
and so
what we introduce is an iterative
algorithm that will automatically
discover the symmetries
um so an overview of the algorithm is
we're going to initialize the set of
equivalence mappings with only the
identity mapping so an action can map to
itself or um and then for each iteration
until convergence there's a protocol
training step which i'm going to go
through the intuition for in the next
slide as um which is going to train a
set of optimal joint policies given the
current set of symmetries so you assume
that the current set of symmetries is
correct and you train policies given
that and then the next step is going to
update the set the set of symmetries and
so this kind of iteration happens until
the the
convergence
all right so now i'm gonna it uh
visually um give intuition for this so
protocol training so
as input for this step it's going to get
the current set of symmetries so of
course that that's initialized to just
the identity matrix um and then it will
initialize a set of joint policies and
then what it wants to return here is um
the some optimal set of joint policies
that it's converged upon
um
and then that is going to be given as
input to for the symmetry discovery step
which will take as input the set of
goals the set of optimal policies joint
policies um uh trained in the previous
step and then the set of symmetries the
current set of symmetries
um and so this is just kind of the high
level and so what it wants to output is
effectively updating the set of
symmetries and then pass that back in so
you see kind of this so this is the high
level structure so i'm going to fill
this in a bit
so over m training episodes um
your the agents will play the signaling
game uh with the set of symmetries
and um that is going to output some
performance for each of the joint
policies so communication success as
well as like a cost
and then
the objective function will be used to
update the policies and i say k samples
here because you can sample from the set
of symmetries multiple times
and then on the right side for every
single goal
um
uh what we're looking at is every single
pair of of policies every single so in
particular i have only sender policies
up here so you see pi one star so all
the all it needs to look at in order to
discover action symmetries are optimal
center policies so given some
communicative goal if i have two
different optimal sender policies i and
j and they take two different actions
for the same goal then i can infer that
those uh actions are symmetric
effectively they can be used
interchangeably and then i want to infer
some mapping between them so this is
nice because it infers equivalence
mappings from a learning perspective
based upon observations and actions of
the of optimal agents it doesn't have to
adhere to the formal mathematical
definition of symmetry as defined by the
decom dp
um
so then what i want to highlight
now is
what does it mean
how do we actually infer the mapping for
the symmetries and then how do we use
that uh in the game
so first how do we infer the mapping
um so
if i have two different actions some
they're just represented as one hot
vectors
and i already know that they're i've
already i already know they're
equivalent because two different optimal
centers took them and effectively i'm
just trying to learn a transformation
matrix and so um
as that's what my equivalence mapping is
so i'm trying to minimize and so we do
is minimize the chao divergence between
action ai and some transformation of aj
that will turn it into ai and then you
know once that is once it converges upon
some transformation matrix that gets
added to the set of symmetries here
um so the implication here is that a
effectively a i and aj these two actions
are in the same equivalence class
all right so returning back to this now
how do we use that in the signaling game
round
um
so now
i'm uh so the sender agent will sample
some goal
um it can it takes an action that action
gets transformed by sampling one of the
uh symmetries in the set of symmetries
so the receiver agent actually sees um a
different action
and then it makes some prediction and so
if the receiver agent made the correct
prediction then the sender learns that i
can um use aj to
communicate gold g
and the receiver learns that a i action
a i
means golgi
and you can imagine in a later
later episode of the game the
relationship gets reversed and so now
the sender updates and says oh actually
i can also take a i
action ai to
um communicate golgi and the receiver
updates it's learning and says oh
actually if i see aj that also means
golgi
that makes sense so this is how these uh
this style gets built up in the game
all right so
um so back to our
the the domain that i showed you
so now
what this algorithm will do is there are
there are many different ways if you you
do self play to um converge on optimal
joint policy under that objective but
when you use um qed which is which is
using the other play objective under the
hood then there's only one way to map
goals to equivalence classes over
actions so um recall that the objective
function
um maximizes mutual information between
goals and equivalence classes over
actions
so here what you notice is for each of
these goals like for goal zero it only
maps to uh one action but for like goal
one it's going to map to an entire
distribution over every action in the
equivalence class um so this is so with
high probability if i know this goal i
know which act which equivalence class
of actions has probability mass in the
space
and then over here
for actions what you notice is for each
of those i mean we actually trained as
such that every action only mapped to
one goal um you could look at multiple
goals and then there's some
disambiguation that needs to happen but
for each of these actions the receiver
policy will only map to only one goal
has probability mass so this is kind of
this is what it looks like empirically
for it to be maximizing this mutual
information between goals and
equivalence classes and then there's
only one way to do this
um
so here is a bunch of self-play joint
policies there are many different ways
to
map using the self-play objective but
only one way to learn optimal joint
policy using a qed algorithm so
what we see is in both algorithms are
able to perform well with a training
partner but um but self-play performance
degrades significantly with a novel
partner or test time even in this simple
domain uh whereas qed it's it's
effectively the same performance because
since they're all learning you know to
my analogy earlier we're all learning
the same language so even if i'm seeing
a new agent at test time i can
communicate successfully with it
um there is one uh trade-off which is or
one key trade-off here which is about
energy costs um and
because
qed is
um
effectively learning
a probability mass over the entire
action space including the costly
actions it's going to overall have more
energy cost
um
yes
so
i
think i have some time so maybe i will
um
go to my hidden slide
do i do it
like a little less than 10 minutes oh
okay great so then let me go to actually
i will have a bit of time to do
some continuous
sorry
okay
um
so in the continuous channel setting uh
which is also which we also um
which we also did uh work on and this is
this is actually
actually originally started continuous
channel setting and then went to the
discrete domain where we realized it was
really hard to do this
but um so here and now instead of um
instead of just this kind of matrix game
kind of set up now the sender is
learning a policy network the receiver
is learning her and the racing receiver
is learning a discriminator network and
motion trajectories are being used as
the messages so this is um this is you
know uh underexplored in the multi-agent
communication the message is in this
high dimensional continuous state in
action space um and then the energy
values are also continuous
uh
now so as opposed to the discrete so
actually we computed the torque of the
trajectories and so
um
so the message space becomes intractably
large here um and
um the method that we use here so it's
still an open question as to how to
um to do uh qed
uh with this high dimensional continuous
setting but we did here do some
self-play training plus and third party
receiver training
um
and then the question with the
continuous setting is zero shot
communication possible in the continuous
setting
um
so uh
so you have this center policy so again
um a goal is sampled the policy takes
some observation
um
and then and the actual goal as input
and then compute
and then outputs and action and that
happens over several different time
steps so now there's an entire
trajectory and so the receiver agent is
going to observe the trajectory by the
sender
i mean you can imagine it could also
take some other sensory input although
in this case it didn't
and then it makes some prediction g
and um it's still the case that the
shared return is a combination of
communication efficacy and cost but now
the cost is actually this continuous
torque um computation
um
yeah
so
here you have each of these um this
represents sender receiver pairs that a
bunch of them are training parallel
uh training the actual initial protocol
and then um
we freeze all of the sender agents and
then we separate them into a train set
in a test set
and um
and then we initialize this third-party
receiver agent that learns a best
response to all of the training senders
and then gets tested on the test sender
so the zero shot communication here is
uh these remember these agents all
trained independently so
if it can uh distill um some kind of
communication protocol from the
different training centers and then uh
perform well against that those that
them the other agents that test time
that zero shot communication
um
so
so again okay so uh this plot um
the vertical axis shows
um
the beginning of training to the end of
training so it's a little bit
counterintuitive because the training is
on the y-axis and then the x-axis is the
actual energy cost so there's only two
so um
we only had two communicative goals here
but what you'd want to see is over the
course of a course of training that
um
goal one will use less energy than gold
two because it's the one that occurs it
occurs about two thirds
two thirds of the time and goal two
occurs about one third of time so this
is what we're seeing
and then at the end of protocol training
this gaussian is basically a gaussian
over the energy cost at the 10 000 marks
at the very bottom
um and so what we see is
that this is um
yeah so this speaks this idea again of
like um mutual information between
uh the goals and the
um actions so
effectively the gaussians are completely
separated which means that um
if i know what the goal is or if it's
the blue goal or the orange goal then
with very high probability i can predict
how much energy is being exerted like
where the actions lie in the energy
space and if i know the actual energy
exertion with very high probability i
can predict the the goal and the class
of actions here is any action that will
exert this much energy
so um the other thing is that they're
pushed all the way to the left which
means it's minimizing costs the
gaussians are as far left as they can go
so this is again showing us that our
objective function is doing what we
expect
and um and it also means that zero shot
communication is possible in principle
if you can if the agent can figure out
that energy is this latent variable it
should be optimizing for
um so here's like a visualization of
so they look quite arbitrary um because
there's no data that's biasing them
but um but it was really cool to see
that
uh given
this um this prior that we used in this
cost constraint that they could be
completely separable in the space and um
and uh infer intent based upon that um
open challenges with the comm with the
continuous setting is that it's
difficult inferring this latent energy
variable
um for high dimensional trajectories
performance degrees significantly as you
increase the number of communicative
goals because effectively it's a
combinatorial search problem so um
and
um and then discovering symmetries for
the continuous channel is is quite um
challenging
um okay
so
yeah so the motivating goal here was the
emergence of communication protocols to
generalize so we have these costly
channels that effectively derive from
energy exertion and i did end up talking
about the high dimensional continuous
channels which are motivated by the idea
of embodied agents
um key contributions of the work is that
we formally introduced the zero shot
communication problem setting
incorporated realistic priors and and
cost constraints to induce bias
theoretical analysis of the
communication objective with equivalence
classes and what that's optimizing for
the qed method and then exploring some
optimization in the continuous action
protocol setting
um and then
some open challenges um
so um
so one
set of things is um
for the serial shot communication
protocols still um analyzing the sample
complexity um so it is um
quite computationally expensive and you
know and this is even for the toy domain
we're doing qed uh so understanding you
know kind of uh what implications that
has and if we can bound that sample
complexity is still something that's
ongoing
um
and then one of the things i didn't show
is that um
when we talk about when i talk about
like converging on optimal joint
policies
that it's very sensitive to where the
joint policies initialize in the space
which is probably not surprising the
interview but
um effectively like one out of ten times
or something that it would actually
converge on a globally optimal solution
so i was doing a lot more computation
than
ideal uh because um it was constantly
falling prey to like locally optimal
solutions and i have some
images of locally optimal solutions if
you're interested but um but this is you
know a key challenge um robustly
converging on the global yacht protocol
um because the entire idea of the zero
shot you know communication is rest upon
agents converging on the same
protocol so the same optimal
um if you want human compatible
protocols and i did motivate this talk
on a high level by humans a while back
um then one has to start thinking about
perhaps using a supervisory signal or
other priors that um can be exploited in
order to make the i mean you saw how
arbitrary the trajectories were so if we
want them to be compatible with humans
then
it needs to be biased towards um
you know the ways in which humans
communicate
um
another thing that i'm quite interested
in these days
is a mixed motive setting so thinking
about social dilemmas and so you know
this whole work has been
set um in a setting where it's fully
cooperative and so you assume that
agents incentives are already aligned
and now the key question becomes how do
you get them to efficiently and
effectively coordinate and communication
can aid in that um
also the case if one thing i didn't list
here is like going beyond referential
games would also be
important for like actual more
interesting coordination challenges
but um another thing that i'm quite
interested in is what about when you
start to add not only this pro sociality
which is you know when you'd have
cooperation but self-interest which i
think is more indicative of the kinds of
um
you know biological agents like humans
and uh then we're looking at not just
thinking about communication protocols
um and information exchange for
efficient coordination which is
effectively what you think about for i
mean that's effectively the purpose of
the communication protocol in a fully
cooperative setting to aid in more
efficient coordination but when you get
to the social dilemma setting then this
communication becomes a negotiation
that's really about trying to align
incentives to enable that cooperation
um
that's it
[Applause]
awesome thanks a lot those are really
interesting work uh let's see does
anyone have uh questions oh yeah danny
two questions um this is just me i think
not understanding enough uh the
non-convexity in your work so that
there's you know you don't have like a
global optimum that's unique uh or like
sorry like a stationary point that's
unique where does that exactly come from
because when i looked at the object when
you look at the objective that you
defined that seemed convex to me
or concave rather
but i guess maybe the costs are not i
see yeah
no that's a good question um
let me go back some
um
here it comes from the fact that
so these different these are different
um
so okay so the so remember i gave the
example of like waving my left hand with
my right hand for example right for the
goal of saying hi you can imagine or
nodding those would be three different
um given that they're different ways of
communicating the same thing like
different actions that effectively are
equivalent
you could the the two agents could
converge on any of those protocols so we
could decide that to say hi we're always
gonna the most efficient thing to do is
not to do some distribution over
different ways because then there's
uncertainty the most efficient thing to
do is learn deterministic protocol so
you we always wavered our right hand to
say hi but then if i am communicating
with someone else then or two other
agents that are converging on a protocol
might always raise their left hand
etcetera so these are these represent um
different joint policies that are
equivalent
um and so the problem is that uh with
self-play
um the assumption basically i adapt to
only my partner my training partner so
we converge on one of these and that's
fine
um
but this is where the non-convexity is
coming from the different ways but then
um oh but then uh the but the the
challenge is that if i'm facing a
different pi pi 2 at test time let's say
pi 2 prime so a different person in the
room that person may have learned a
protocol where they with their left hand
which means they converged on a
different
so what we want is only one option so
everybody is learning to do with their
left hand and then that way i see you
and we're doing the same thing
that makes sense yeah
um and then have you also considered
like models where you have multiple
centers and multiple receivers uh and
they have to maybe coordinate amongst
each other
like how would you generalize this do
you have any ideas
yeah basically um yeah actually i
started with doing experiments with that
um in the continuous settings there's
lots of things we try to continue
setting but basically each sender
learns a best response to all the
different receivers and uh so
effectively
you can imagine basically a training
time you're sampling if i'm a sender the
different receivers are being sampled
over the course of many different
episodes i would have seen many
different receivers and my i'm updating
my policy as a response to all of the
and then same for the receivers but you
still but then when you go to zero shot
the problem is you still want
independently trained which means a
different population of senders and
receivers so you still have the same
problem which is why we ended up coming
to just the single center receiver case
because it didn't it didn't add any
value to have like 10
you know a population of 20 or 10
receivers in 10 senators
oh yeah let's see over here
thanks for the talk really cool stuff um
can you say a little bit more about what
you did for a policy search would you
just run like a dozen
optimization algorithms from different
initial points and hope that one of them
found the global optimum
yes basically
yeah different initialization so i mean
like a smart so i mean you know things
that i have thought about and had
conversations around like a smarter
initialization
um
would be one thing that could be helpful
about um um
a better exploration
uh policy because it was just um like
entropy or so it was pretty naive um in
terms of the
uh so both of those might be helpful in
terms of um
converging to a better
uh a better uh
do you have any way of certifying
whether you're at a global optimum or
not
or you just after you've run all 12 hope
that you've found the best
yeah i mean i
currently know uh so basically what we
did is take the top uh i mean so
empirically what i noticed is about 10 i
mean at least 10 percent of the time it
was converging on the global optimum so
we scored them and then it just took the
top 10 uh and then assumed that that
should and typically that worked okay
okay but it feels hacky um i mean it's
it's fine i mean this is not hacky but
it feels like not
that's not an ideal way to deal with it
it feels like qed is pretty brittle to
this too so it's it's important to get
right yeah i mean and to be fair this is
a bigger problem in
optimization when you have you know
neural networks and so it's not like
it's just this but it's very sensitive
to converging on a global optimum so
even though this problem is a larger
problem that's not unique to qed it's
one that like you said the qed is quite
yeah yeah okay cool thanks
um
yeah so i had a question about
when you discover the symmetries how do
you ensure that the senders
not like collapse into just one mode
i know if that was clear
so in like
in your training loop you are first
training some agents
then you are basically uh i guess
computing the symmetries that they
discovered
and then using that to train again
but what if they all collapse to the
same protocol
just at the beginning
oh i mean oh i see so basically this is
where the number of
so you you see these end joint policies
because effectively what you want is
diversity across the joint policies so
um this is where it's important to i
mean empirically we try different
numbers like if you only have like two
joint policies that you're training then
it's more likely the case that you're
not going to get sufficient diversity to
be able to discover all the symmetries
so
having a high number of those is one way
to
to get closer to that but i mean ideally
something that
from an algorithmic perspective if you
had um
if you added a part of the algorithm
that would again do better in terms of
exploration or do a smarter like a more
informed exploration or like
maximizing diversity across the
different
um
across the different uh
joint policies that are being trained
then you would be more confident that
the different senders will be learning
different ways of communicating the same
goals and so you should be able to
discover those symmetries um or you
should be able to discover all the
symmetries that exist okay um because i
guess my intuition would be that it
doesn't always converge to the global
optimum because it collapses at some
point and you don't discover
all the
symmetries
do you think it would be possible that
it's related to that
uh
i think that it has to do with
uh
two things i mean so the initialization
but also it's a multi-objective
optimization problem so it's trying to
is trying to um
optimize between communication
accuracy or prediction accuracy and cost
and so it's not entirely clear uh i mean
if not when i watch the optimization for
example it's not entirely clear
how to best do that at what point i mean
it starts for example by trying to drive
down cost then at some point it starts
optimizing for communication accuracy i
mean this is what i would see
empirically but if you haven't if you
haven't driven down costs enough then
you may be near
a locally optimal communication protocol
and so then when it starts trying to
optimize for
um communication success it converges on
a
communication protocol that's locally
optimal so i think so basically a lot of
the challenge has to do with the fact
that it is also a multi-objective
optimization that it's doing and um and
we tried like maybe having a curriculum
over the different objectives and
um so we tried playing with a few things
but i think that is a key issue
okay thanks a lot
hi so hey yeah maybe again with the
issue of that that
converges to the global optimum like one
out of ten times like you're you were
talking for future work maybe biasing
the agents towards more like human
uh like biases with this help guiding
them not necessary towards the global
optimum but at least like to a pretty
good um
like say let's say local optimum with
would you have any intuition on that or
yeah i mean so to be fair i have been
talking about uh
optimality and converging on some
globally optimal solution and maybe that
affects my own bias but the reality of
it is they just need to converge on the
same solution it doesn't i mean even
worse of optimal if it were the same
then we could communicate
so
um so
it could be the case that if you had now
if you have human data then that's
biasing them and maybe it forms a
stronger bias and then they converge
near that and then yeah so um but then
of course that's a that's a slightly
different
uh way to approach the problem because
now you're using data to bias as opposed
to like going with strict like strictly
like um optimization
yeah but but i i i do believe that that
is a different approach that could be
um you know quite helpful for
yeah i was maybe thinking in a practical
sense like this is the cleanest version
of the problem yeah yeah and
particularly with the continuous ones i
think you know okay i definitely think
you need data there because then with
the continuous ones the trajectory space
is
so large right so then if you knew if
you had human demonstrations then you
would prune the trajectory space
significantly and you'd know that like
oh really only
like wiggling my toe is not actually a
trajectory i should consider right like
only
this and so some some trajectories near
these spaces so i think for the discrete
domain uh it wasn't as important to
think about this data and and really
dive into like
the interesting problems around the
difference between self play and
but for a continuous domain you know you
think about robots or something and also
for like safety reasons and whatever
else i think data becomes probably much
more important
yeah and also like you talked about
theoretical sample complexity but in
practice because the agents need to
learn these equivalent mappings how much
longer does it take like compared to
just the regular self-play dude
oh it takes significantly longer um
um yeah i mean it's which is why i would
like to understand
uh
i mean for me like seeing the
abstraction would help me to get
um
a better idea of
what that means but
um
i'm trying to look at this to tell you
where
where that comes in
um
you know
yeah let's talk about that offline
because i feel like
i haven't seen this work in a little
while so i haven't really uh
uh been diving into it since i've been a
deep mind to be so i have to remember
where it was but it but uh adding the
symmetry discovery is is quite expensive
yeah okay
thanks
let's take one more question yeah
thanks um so
one thing that i really like about about
um qed is that it gives you the
symmetries kind of like for free um and
then
especially in the example you gave with
the hand waving i kind of think of these
symmetries as like messages that have
similar semantic meaning
and
so
maybe not in this setting where where
the game is like referential and kind of
like single round but i was wondering if
you could
um lift these symmetries to translate
the messages that the agents are
communicating so for example
in the uh more dutch and abio work that
you had a few slides back they have this
like compositional language and a much
more like embodied environment and so on
um and then they just like hand
translate the messages to give the
reader some intuition but like getting
an automatic translation for these
things would be really cool so you could
i was wondering
if you thought about taking this in the
like translation direction or what do
you think some pitfalls of using the
symmetries for that might be oh yeah
that's an interesting question
so i haven't thought about it um but i
do i think that if you have if you if
you have data which is going to give
rise to semantic meaningfulness
then like human data then i think then
it might be
then it might be the case that you can
look at some distance between
trajectories that the agent that the
agents are converging upon and like
trajectories that you have in your data
set and try to understand like
semantically what this
you know is close to or um i mean all of
it i mean also even if you didn't have
even if you didn't have a like some
distance metric you know um or even if
you didn't have like a data set where
you could do a distance metric
i think you know looking at the
trajectories is oftentimes meaningful
because they are trying to minimize
energy so you can see you know how
mapping is some goal that occurs really
frequently should be much less motion
and less velocity than um a goal that
occurs with much less frequency but
particularly for like goals that occur
with much less frequency they can have
arbitrarily
very weird trajectories and and it's
hard to make sense of them so i think i
think data would be a key aspect
there and then it could be interesting
to to see if there's something
meaningful but kind of like you know
what a lot of the emerging communication
people do from a language perspective
when they're trying to discover some
kind of syntactic structure or something
like this yeah
all right when we uh stop there uh let's
uh thank alicia again that was uh yeah i
mean
i think really stop provoking talk
okay so let's uh come back uh
at 10 15 for the next talk okay
cool